Carl Schmidt decided he wanted to kill
him it was in his bones like bone marrow
I want to kill he thought thinking he
walked into the empty white room with
white walls and white floor and white
ceiling the sad man was on the floor a
look of Terror in his fear struck face
you disgusting idiot you Carl in toned I
have a family stated the man in fear and
Terror so did I but your Insidious
actions led to the dark Forces of or
reaching them and using them as leverage
against my CIA knowledge and they
murdered them and it was your fault
you dumb Carl screeched yes the man
recalled bleeding Carl grabbed him
picked him up spun him slammed him on
the ground he flipped him on his side he
also kicked his groin
F the man bowed Carl twirled him around
75 times before smashing his knees with
his big Iron boots blood was everywhere
the man screamed ouch but Carl flipped
him again and flung him out the window
the man plummeted then every inch of him
exploded in every direction as he
smashed it with pavement coating
everything in blood ha Carl heaved from
his mouth a smile exploded on to his
face